[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
today we're going to be discussing
wizarding prisons
a few months back i broke down all the
known schools in the international
wizarding community
and today similar to that i'm going to
be pivoting to international prisons
everyone knows azkaban but do you know
the mother seven
let's dive into it number one nurman god
known by some as the home base for
grindelwald's operations during his
tyrannical regime spanning the early
1900s and known by others as the castle
that ended up keeping grindelwald as its
prisoner nurmengard is after azgaban
probably the most famous wizarding
prison in harry potter
located in the austrian alps grindelwald
built norman guard 2 1 act as his base
of operations for him and his followers
and two hold his enemies and prisoners
of war
sitting on the edge of a mountain the
stone fortress had massive tall walls
and boasted an impressive tower with a
cone-shaped top
presumably serving as a kind of
watchtower
the grounds of nurmangard were nothing
to scoff at either featuring a gated
courtyard from which you could sit and
look at the beautiful scenery all around
that is if you weren't distracted by the
prison bars on either side of the
courtyard that were used to keep the
less powerful prisoners captive
inside is where the prisoners that he
felt were a real threat were kept inside
of the prison was just as spectacular as
the mountains around it at least while
grindelwald was still in power
it was outfitted with tall windows
velvet carpets and long corridors the
perfect prison for a bougie villain like
grindelwald and if at first it wasn't
completely obvious that this was
grindelwald's fortress
the massive for the greater good slogan
carved over the prison's entrance would
be a good reminder ironically
grindelwald ended up being imprisoned in
nurmengard himself the primary reason
being that grindelwald had ties to
austria
that and the fact that the wizarding
authorities thought it would be
entertaining to imprison him inside the
walls that he built
if nurman guard didn't exist then i'm
almost certain that he would have ended
up in azkaban
years later it was reported that
nurmengard had deteriorated
significantly
it no longer had the upkeep of
grindelwald's acolytes and it simply
served as a prison which it grew to look
like more and more as the years passed
eventually nurmengard was nothing more
than a giant towering building made of
black rock that can only be described as
grim and ominous
2. azkaban azkaban was built in the 15th
century and began being used as a
detention facility in the year 1718
housing some of the most sinister
witches and wizards to have ever
disgraced the wizarding world
the name azkaban is a mixture of the
word alcatraz which refers to a famous
mughal island prison and abaddon which
is a hebrew word that means place of
destruction
sounds wonderful doesn't it
at one point in time before the fortress
was built azkaban was just an island but
when its first inhabitant ecrisdis found
the island he decided to transform it
into his own little dark arts experiment
ecrisdis was a dark wizard that
practiced the worst forms of dark magic
and he was known to lure sailors to the
island then torture them
before he got there he was crazy but
after spending a considerable amount of
time there he went completely bonkers
while the christus lived there he placed
concealment charms on the island so that
no one would be able to find it and
after he died these concealment charms
were finally lifted
this is when the british ministry of
magic first discovered the island the
investigative team from the ministry who
first went to azkaban refused to discuss
their findings other than the fact that
the island was infested with dementors
over the course of its history azkaban
has been home to many witches and
wizards including percival dumbledore
martinez crouch jr various lestrangers
and various gaunts just to name a few
though it was under much scrutiny
initially when the ministry recognized
that they could utilize the island to
imprison evildoers they capitalized on
this and began sentencing people to
azgaban
the ministry of magic felt that the
smaller existing wizarding prisons that
were scattered across the country
imposed a considerable security risk and
put citizens in danger
azkaban serves as the ultimate prison
due to its remote location and the sea
of dementors that make sure the
prisoners are in check
escaping from azkaban before your
sentence is over is punishable by fate
worse than death a dementor's kiss
the island itself is located in the
north sea
but the island is said to have never
appeared on any map muggle or magical
it's suspected that the island was
either created or enlarged via magical
means i'm thinking that accrisdas was
probably responsible for that
the north sea is a marginal sea of the
atlantic ocean located between great
britain denmark norway germany the
netherlands belgium and france
if you're going to get locked up try
your absolute best to avoid azkaban
3. irkstarg
first witnessed by fans in the new
secrets of dumbledore film the irkstark
was a wizarding prison located in berlin
germany that was used by the german
ministry of magic
the irkstarg could be accessed via an
underground tunnel system and many
believe that the prison had been
publicly abandoned
however as it turns out and as we
witnessed in these secrets of dumbledore
the german ministry were still secretly
holding people at the facility by 1932
at the entrance to the prison there was
a prison guard a warder who would
confiscate each prisoner's personal
belongings upon their arrival
the prison itself which had a circular
shape and spiraled downwards was dark
scary and certainly not the sort of
place you'd want to end up particularly
as your chances of getting out at least
from the way the film portrayed it were
likely quite slim
from what appeared to be near the bottom
of the endless spiraling prison
structure was a giant manticore that
would devour prisoners as soon as their
lanterns went out
dumbledore once referred to irkstarg as
the german ministry's bed and breakfast
4. macoosa prison macusa aka the magical
congress of the united states of america
was essentially the american ministry of
magic and just like the german ministry
of magic macusa 2 had their own prison
directly linked with their organization
the macusa headquarters was located in
the woolworth building in downtown new
york city and the prison cells were
located in the basement
it's entirely unclear how long these
prison cells have existed but provided
that macusa was founded in 1693
i'd wager it's been a long time
yes the woolworth building was completed
in 1913 but provided the prison cells
were located in the basement of the
building it's entirely possible that
they were there before the building had
even been built hiding underground
reportedly the main cell room held
hundreds of cage-like cells stacked on
top of each other
sort of like what you'd expect to see at
a dog pound and in the middle of the
main room there was a large staircase
with iron bars on both sides that led up
to the rooftop of the woolworth building
though the building was clean and
relatively well kept it certainly didn't
mean that prisoners there had a good
experience
in fact prisoners were kept in strangely
dark rooms devoid of windows accessible
only through one ominous looking iron
door with a tiny sliding window big
enough only to fit your eyes
5. dark tower hogwarts a prison at
hogwarts yes you heard me right
just near the transfiguration courtyard
at hogwarts you may recall a tall narrow
tower
this dark looking tower aptly named the
dark tower was in fact used as a prison
at hogwarts however provided that this
prison was at a school for children
and given that there were only a few
cells i'd probably call it more of a
holding facility the tower itself was
seven stories tall
and sported four gargoyles on each
corner of the tower directing water away
from it when it rained it has also been
reported that the prison cells were not
outfitted with any kind of incantations
making it a lot less secure than other
wizarding prisons we know
while in the present day there may not
be much need for a prison cell at
hogwarts we do have to remember that
back in the day before azgaban prisons
were scattered all across the country
having a holding cell or at least
something at hogwarts a massive hub for
witches and wizards probably made a lot
of sense
in the film version of the prisoner of
azkaban sirius black is held prisoner in
this tower
however in the books he's kept in
phillies flipwick's office over in the
west tower
6. new york witch's penitentiary
the new york witch's penitentiary first
mentioned on a poster in fantastic
beasts and where to find them was a
women's only wizarding prison located in
the state of new york
past prisoners include madame miraforum
eleanor shanks and matilda's heisenberg
all of these women were highly dangerous
criminals at large with crimes ranging
from no maj murder to atrocities against
the wizarding community
i feel like bellatrix would have fit
right in here
and that pretty much concludes the list
of the main prisons the only other two
wizarding prisons if you could call them
that that i know of are the abandoned
substation which was used as a holding
facility for snatchers to hold
muggleborns and the abandoned nuclear
power plant which was used to imprison
enemies of the death eater controlled
ministry of magic
these facilities appeared in the harry
potter games
and can be seen in the background of
some of the harry potter film
promotional posters
and that's it for this video did i miss
any had you heard of all of these
prisons leave a comment down below
if you enjoyed the content please like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you